hi I'm Bryce Dallas Howard and I'm one
of the Chris's this is your weekends
ticket oh my god Chris Pratt and bdh
said the name on my show that's my show
I mean this is your weekend ticket
[Music]
millions of years in the making and it's
finally here Jurassic world fallen
Kingdom this is the second installment
of the Jurassic world series which is a
sequel series to the original Jurassic
Park trilogy with the remaining
dinosaurs threatened by an island
destroying volcano our heroes must
decide their stance on the ethical
implications of saving the man-made Dino
clones from Isla Nublar and if they're
up to the challenge
it seems pretty simple what could go
wrong with stunning visuals riveting
action sequences and explosive on-screen
chemistry between Chris Pratt and Bryce
Dallas Howard this is a movie that you
have to see on the big screen you'll
love Jurassic world fallen Kingdom if
you're a fan of any or all of the
Jurassic movies Chris Pratt humor +
action is your thing or if you love
movies based on true stories oh what
it's not it's not based on a true story
I find that very surprising honestly
that is your weekend ticket and if
Jurassic world were a real place would
you go Reza comment check back next week
by the way the Shaq attack is back in
uncle Drew
[Music]